there is an effort being made by the
current administration and by the people
surrounding it to redefine what treason
is and it's genuinely menacing when we
see these authoritarian slides we have
to understand that they're often slow
slides it's the slow erosion of what it
means to have a truly free and
independent press for example and it
gets chipped away at a little bit at a
time by the idea of suing media outlets
journalism licenses stricter White House
press past policies the smears about
fake news it's a long list but they're
really slow attempt less and less
frequent press briefings by the White
House press secretary it's a slow
process that you have to observe from
afar rather than day to day another
example the slow erosion of the
independence of our branches of
government and the systems of checks and
balances including the investigative
power of the House and Senate ignoring
subpoenas getting your own attorney
general in there to manage the results
of an investigation into you etc etc etc
so it's important to realize that these
things happen slowly and it can be I
don't even know if this is an actual
thing but you often hear about the frog
that goes into a cold pan you start
heating up the pan heats up slowly the
Frog doesn't realize it's being burned
that may not even work maybe the Frog
just jumps out when it gets hot but
that's the metaphor that I think many of
us are familiar with and there is now a
slow but very sure and creeping slide to
redefine treason by the administration
yesterday
Donald Trump published or retweeted an
article that quotes Liz Cheney the
daughter of former Vice President Dick
Cheney as saying that statements made by
agents investigating Donald Trump could
be treason and in the length interview
Liz Cheney even says that FBI agents who
investigated Trump could have been
attempting a coup these are attempts at
redefinition if you control the language
you control everything I forget who
where that quote is from they are trying
to control the language treason treason
is the crime of betraying one's country
especially by attempting to kill the
sovereign or overthrow the government
that is not what the investigations into
Donald Trump sought to do they certainly
weren't attempting to kill the sovereign
and they were not attempting to
overthrow the government they were
investigating whether Donald Trump
specifically committed crimes a coup is
a sudden violent and illegal seizure of
power from a government of course those
investigating Donald Trump didn't
attempt to do that and if Donald Trump
were to leave there would be no seizure
of power from a government it would
likely be Mike Pence takes over although
there are other scenarios as well so
what you have to understand is that they
are systematically trying to change the
meaning of these things in order to
favor their position on whatever in this
case these investigations and in fact
Donald Trump was asked about his treason
claim recently a few days ago and look
at what happened and in further fact uh
I should mention as far as Liz Cheney is
concerned Liz Cheney if she wants to
talk about treason the closest thing to
treason she might be well-positioned to
comment on would be the war crimes that
her dad Dick Cheney participated in
within the Bush administration and even
then it is dubious whether you could
actually make a treason case there as
many legal experts have said so here's
Donald Trump asked about treason is
punishable by death who exactly are you
talking about - she says treason is
punishable by death you've accused your
adversaries of treason who specifically
are you accusing of treason well I think
a number of people and I think what you
look is that they have unsuccessfully
tried to take down the wrong person if
you look at Comey if you look at McCabe
if you look at probably people hot
people higher than that if you look at
struck if you look at his lover lisa
page his wonderful lover the two lovers
they talked openly you know they didn't
use their private server because they
didn't want to get caught so they used
the government server that was not a
good move he talked about the insurance
policy just in case crooked Hillary
losses and that didn't work out too well
for them so you look at them they want
an insurance policy so that should she
for any reason
remember 100 million to one maybe he
said 100 million to nothing but should
she lose we'll have an insurance policy
and we'll get this guy out of office and
that's what they said and that's what
they meant that's treason that's treason
they couldn't win the election and
that's what happened and that's what's
happening right now because without the
treason word I guess but that's what's
happening now James Comey John McCain
Peter struck who was working for Moeller
and was dismissed when politically
biased private text messages went public
as far as Democrats not thinking they
can win without trying to remove Trump
forcibly or whatever it's the opposite
it's been Trump who has been saying
Democrats can't win fair and square in
2020 which is how Trump has been hinting
at the possibility of not accepting the
results of the election if he loses this
is complete and total projection and
there's a real question here I don't
know the answer to this if a president
publicly accuses you of treason by name
is there any recourse is that defamation
the act of damaging the good reputation
of someone slander or libel when the
president says that specific individuals
have committed a crime but not just any
crime the crime of treason is there any
recourse that those individuals have and
is that really where we are right now
we've got to take control back there's
no other way around it this is becoming
extremely dangerous and these
redefinitions should be concerning to
everybody who's been paying attention to
what's going on and this is not
happening by accident this is a
concerted effort to start throwing
around the word treason particularly at
a time when what we are learning is that
there was wrongdoing by Trump remember
and everybody around him it's an attempt
to distract from that and instead say
the investigators are the individuals
who were treasonous we can't fall for it
and we've got to act sooner than later
November of 2020 in order to stop this
insanity I have some really great video
today of one of the most prominent
bad-faith
actors that have surfaced as
brown-nosing Don
from sycophants during the last two
years and I'm talking of course about
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham the
trump presidency has been sort of great
for Lindsey Graham and also a complete
and total embarrassment for him so on
the one hand Trump has been great for
Lindsey Graham because Lindsey Graham
sucking up to trump has gotten him tons
of airtime he's way more known today
than he was before the Trump presidency
and in a sense his sort of personal
profile has risen drastically under
Donald Trump on the other hand though
Lindsey Graham has been caught in
hilarious contradiction after
contradiction and if you're paying
attention you realize that Graham is a
completely farcical political tool with
no concern whatsoever for the truth or
for what's right and I told you back in
April you might remember that even
though Lindsey Graham now says Trump
can't be impeached for any cover-up
actions like for example obstruction
because there was no underlying crime
for example conspiracy to collude with
Russia or whatever we found video of
Lindsey Graham despite that from the
Clinton era where he was actually
ranting on the Senate floor about how
Bill Clinton can be impeached even
though there was no underlying crime so
more recently I've told you that the
Trump administration is ignoring endless
subpoenas for documents and directing
witnesses to ignore subpoenas and
Lindsey Graham thinks that that's fine
as long as it's the Trump administration
but it turns out there's a Lindsey just
like there's a Trump tweet for anything
it seems that there's a Lindsey Graham
video for anything it turns out that
back in the late 1990s Graham also said
that ignoring congressional subpoenas or
directing others to do so is an
impeachable offense for a President of
the United States of course when the
president at the time happened to be
Democratic President Bill Clinton so Fox
News's Chris Wallace tried to call out
Lindsey Graham and it's pretty
interesting he plays the video for
Graham Graham doesn't really know which
way is up or what what's going on and
what he comes up with is just saying
well the difference is Republicans act
in good faith and Democrats act in bad
faith that that's basically what it
comes down to and this all has to do if
you haven't been following it
and I really didn't while I was on break
but I've caught myself up on it this all
has to do with Democrats trying to get
more information about the molar report
redacted versions unredacted versions
bar etc and that sets up the following
exchange on fox news you call all of
what's going on here in Washington a
political circus but you took it a
different view back when you were
leading the impeachment effort against
Bill Clinton back in the late 90s at
that time you said that any president
and you talked specifically about
Clinton and Richard Nixon who defied
Congress when it came to subpoenas was
in danger of impeachment here you are
back then you're becoming the judge and
jury it is not your job to tell us what
we need it is your job to comply all the
things we need to provide oversight over
you question why is it an impeachable
offense for Clinton or Nixon back then
to ignore congressional subpoenas but
it's ok for president Trump to do now
well there's two things here the Moller
investigation was a special counsel
appointed to find out if the president
committed a crime if he colluded with
the russians if you obstructed justice
the president gave him 1.4 million
documents to muller everybody around the
president was allowed to testify he
never claimed executive privilege he
complied no cover-up work with mother
Muller's the final word on this for me
so if Clinton had stiff Kent Starr
that's different
what Nadler is doing is trying to
destroy the president and his family if
I were the president I'd fight back
against this political revenge coming
out of the house Muller was the man of
the law Muller was an independent voice
that we all trusted to be fair I don't
trust House Democrats to be fair they're
trying to redo the Muller report they're
trying to make up other stuff and at the
end of the day it will be political
suicide for them to impeach if I were
the president I would fight Nadler tooth
and nail I'm glad it cooperated with
Muller that's the difference so Lindsey
Graham's explanation is when he was
calling people out in the 90s the
Republican Party was a responsible
respectable good faith actor and most
importantly they could be trusted not to
act in a politically biased way they
were just doing the right thing but 20
19 Democrats can't be trusted right
they are the political ones but
Republicans impeaching Clinton in the
1990s weren't being political I'm having
a hard time imagining a more outrageous
explanation like if you said come up
with a more ridiculous way to explain
the contradiction I don't know that I
could do better than the absurdity of
what Lindsey Graham actually said but I
want to try to zoom out a little bit and
take like a bigger picture view here
rather than focusing on the specifics of
Lindsey Graham's blatant and obvious
political posturing
none of these elected officials have
your best interests in mind
meaning Democrats play political games
and Republicans play political games
Democrats play politics with subpoenas
and congressional testimony and
Republicans do the exact same thing
there were rampant politics around the
Bill Clinton impeachment and the Ken
Starr investigation no matter what
Lindsey Graham says and yes there are
rampant politics today from Democrats
around the Trump stuff but don't mistake
what I'm saying for me playing this both
sides do it equally sort of thing I'm
not doing the phone neutrality BS that
you might hear on some other shows the
pathetic fence sitting milquetoast
everybody is doing the same stuff on
both sides thing that adds nothing the
conversation that's not what I mean both
sides play politics with all of this but
when Republicans were doing it with Bill
Clinton it was about a lie related to
oral sex okay Democrats are now using
the same I admit these are tired tactics
these are depressing political
techniques but Democrats are doing it to
try to figure out the full scope of what
criminality may have been undertaken by
the President of the United States and
people around him to figure out the full
scope of the kleptocratic disaster that
is this administration that has been
participating in a deliberate self
enrichment and and and violations or
moves away from the systems of checks
and balances that we have so yeah both
sides do this
garbage congressional subpoenas are
political tools a lot of these things
are political tools that we've been
seeing for decades on this uh in this
country but you have to understand the
pernicious role that bottom feeders like
Lindsey Graham have in 2019 versus
thinking back to the 90s and what Bill
Clinton's impeachment was all about do
not fall for this truly moronic
explanation for Lindsey Graham now
unfortunately Chris Wallace didn't
really follow up about the absurdity of
it but at least we got the clip that we
got let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
speaking of voting in November by the
way Texas has had an acting Secretary of
State and this man named David Whitley
of course a Republican has now resigned
after wrongly questioning the
citizenship of almost 100,000 people and
even more hilarious is that in his
resignation letter he didn't even
mention the botched voter purge that
took place in Texas at all the
resignation letter is a blatant
whitewashing of what actually happened
the voter purge was actually ended back
in April and there was a settlement that
was reached with civil rights groups who
sued over it and what's even more insane
about all of this is that under the
terms of the agreement that was reached
over this voter purge the next Secretary
of State whoever it ends up being can
keep trying to identify non-citizens and
remove them from the voter rolls as long
as they put in place some better
screening methods so that they get more
accurate results now that piece actually
makes sense I mean if you zoom out
states should be allowed to remove
non-citizens from voter rolls that
that's perfectly reasonable the problem
is that in practice it's been made
crystal clear that it's a tactic
motivated by voter suppression to help
Republicans period the way it went down
is that they claimed to have found
95,000 non-citizens registered to vote
they started sending these lists out to
the individual county officials to start
pulling those people off of the voter
rolls and then very quickly they
admitted an accord
agreed oh yeah that list was bogus it
wasn't actually made up of non-citizens
registered to vote but of course by then
it was too late to stop the propaganda
war a fact Donald Trump was tweeting
about it saying look rampant voter fraud
here's an example from Texas and Trump
actually claimed that of those 95,000
non-citizens who were supposedly
identified by Texas 58,000 voted and of
course everything was a lie a federal
judge ruled that way saying there wasn't
widespread voter fraud and this Whitley
guys strategy was a complete and total
mess so here are the key takeaways
number one this is all part of the
untrue story that Trump's been telling
us since November of 2016 and
Republicans have been telling us for
even longer than that that millions of
people are voting illegally with Trump
specifically it was three to five
million people voted illegally Hillary
Clinton didn't really win the popular
vote it was because of those three to
five million illegal boats this is so
laughably false at this point that I
don't even want to spend that much time
on it the more important thing to
understand here is that we can't let the
right play games with this to make it
seem as though we on the left want
people to vote illegally okay because
every time we call out the horrible
implementation of these strategies that
the right does deliberately to
disenfranchise likely Democratic voters
or those more likely to be Democratic
voters they will say hold on lefties are
you saying you want people voting
illegally you're saying you don't want
to remove people who aren't citizens
from voter rolls see you're part of the
problem so we've got to be prepared to
take that head-on and the answer is the
position is obvious of course we want
only legal voters voting and
overwhelmingly that's what happens every
major study has found that fraudulent
votes are almost non-existent they're
statistically insignificant when it
comes to the results of actual elections
the reason that we are correct to be
suspicious and disgusted with
Republicans doing this stuff is not
because we want the legal votes it's
because it's not a problem and the right
has admitted behind closed doors and we
even have video of them admitting it in
public in
cases they are doing all of this to hurt
the left higher turnout helps the helps
the left more voting helps the left
voting access helps the left so don't
allow them to change the narrative we're
against illegal voters they barely exist
though and the real issue is voter
suppression it's not voter fraud and
this has been a at this point I don't
know it is could we say it's a
multi-decade effort to suppress votes in
a way that is strategically advantageous
to Republicans don't let them play the
games a good that this guy Whitley has
resigned bad that he was able to
whitewash the resignation with this
bogus resignation letter and now we've
got to see who it is that the governor
Abbott is going to nominate probably
won't be out until after the 2020
election so I already told you about
Donald Trump with another example of his
just terrible judgment initially saying
that he's fine with the North Korean
missile launch that later he says didn't
actually happen this is a serious
concern or at least it should be for the
movement that cares about rationality
and critical thinking and modern
geopolitical relationships and really
everything else under the umbrella of
what I like to call reality if you care
about reality if you want to operate in
a world where reality influences our
views and decisions and our sort of
place in the world as humans then you
have to recognize that the fact that
there's something very wrong with Donald
Trump's judgment is an existential risk
to the United States and when we look
back at all of these examples of trumps
poor judgment I mean just to give you a
few Trump's repeated statements that he
believed Russian President Vladimir
Putin that Russia didn't interfere in
the 2016 US election that was Trump
using what he believes to be his good
judgment which is not to read a guy like
Vladimir Putin and to come away saying I
believe him I trust them I think he's
telling me the truth of course we now
have endless dozens and dozens of
assessments and the Moller report and
everything else which tells us actually
American intelligence conclusions were
right from the beginning about Russian
interference that one we talked about a
lot we just talked about the North Korea
example
five minutes ago Trump said he doesn't
think that Kim jong-un and the regime
did anything in violation of the UN
Security Council resolutions with the
recent launch you'll remember that
Donald Trump also said he doesn't
believe that anybody high up at North
Korea in North Korea had anything to do
with or even awareness of what happened
with the death of otto warmbier remember
when Donald Trump said this I know the
warmbier family very well I think
they're an incredible family what
happened is horrible
I really believe something very bad
happened to him and I don't think that
the top leadership knew about it and
when they had to send him home by the
way I got the prisoners back I got the
hostages back and Otto was one of the
hostages but I don't came back in shape
that was not even to be talked about I
find it I thought it was horrible now
the others came back extremely healthy
but Otto came back in a condition that
was just just terrible and I will I did
speak about it and I don't believe that
he would have allowed that to happen
just wasn't to his advantage to allow
that to happen
kim jeong-hoon or at least the top
leadership knows when there are
Americans being held in North Korea
their value is huge to the North Korean
propaganda machine and it is an
absolutely absurd assertion that Donald
Trump made and another example of his
poor judgment there's lots of other
examples where it's more a question of
is Trump's judgment bad or is he just
dumb like when he said Mexico's going to
pay for the wall any sensible person
realized they were never going to pay
for it it just wasn't going to happen
and Donald Trump insisted that they were
is that that judgment is that being dumb
is that deliberately lying I'm not
really sure Trump had the bad judgment
to choose Michael Flynn as a national
security adviser despite having been
warned multiple times by multiple people
including Barack Obama about Michael
Flynn we know how that ended with
Michael Flynn indicted Trump had the bad
judgment to attack John McCain endlessly
even after John McCain
died the disastrous judgment which led
Trump to start this endless unwinnable
trade war with China which allows Russia
to swoop in and improve their
relationship with China increasingly
leaving the United States out to pasture
the limitless bad judgment of violating
the Iran deal even though Iran didn't
violate the deal which as I told you two
weeks ago is now leading Iran to resume
researching nuclear technology
predictable and an internally logical
move from Iran's point of view and the
more I think about it I actually don't
know whether these are examples of bad
judgment or of Trump being simply
ignorant or of Donald Trump being a bad
person but in either case it's the
mother lode of bad decisions and bad
positions that are coming from Donald
Trump's inability or unwillingness to
actually judge situations for what they
are
we're sort of in a 1984 esque
era in that way I know that in the last
couple years I've said that a lot of
elements of what's going on today are
less like 1984 and more like brave new
world by Aldous Huxley this particular
thing is more in 1984 thing right war is
peace
freedom is slavery ignorance is strength
everything's backwards nothing is as it
seems and Donald Trump even said that
trying to remember something like what
you were seeing and hearing you
shouldn't believe or you can't believe
what you were seeing and hearing it's
good to be back from my vacation and my
trip because we've got to get down to
business with removing this menace
because it is becoming extraordinarily
belligerent and significantly more
urgent particularly as these long-term
relationships are broken and bad
decisions are made and it's going to
take whoever replaces Trump Bibi it in
two years I guess more like a year and a
half now whether it's in a year and a
half or in five and a half years whoever
ultimately replaces Donald Trump is
going to have years of work to do to fix
the problems that Donald Trump has
created make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram to vote
in this week's poll at David Pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much much more
after this it's great to be back let's
talk about 2020 polling okay it's been
weeks since I talked about the
Democratic primary polling partially
it's because I was gone all of last week
but partially it's because we've not
been following it super closely at this
point but we're now getting close to the
start of the Democratic primary debates
those start next month and at this point
there are some really clear and defined
trends in 2020 Democratic primary
polling and the trends are for better or
worse Joe Biden is leading but not by as
much as he was at the beginning of May
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren have
solidified their second and third-place
positions Kamala Harris and Peter Budaj
are kind of trading back and forth for
the fourth place position and then
they're just like are a whole bunch of
candidates who can't even break one or
one percent or two percent who are
effectively done and have no chance so I
want to go through this in order and
let's see kind of what we're left with
at the end first of all the green line
if you are watching along with me here
is Joe Biden's polling and I'll describe
it in case you're listening and not
watching Joe Biden's polling hit a high
average of more than 40% early in May
and it's now sort of cooled off to just
under 35 percent so Biden has lost
somewhere around six or seven points
depending on the poll you look at over
the last three to four weeks the
question is is Biden going to keep
trailing off or will he stick around 35%
the progressive wing of the left is
saying the more people know about Joe
the more his support is going to erode
because people aren't going to like what
Joe Biden is about that's a possibility
it also could be that there was some
initial enthusiasm behind Joe that is
just kind of falling off now okay so
that's number one
number two you look at the light blue
and the brown lines on this image that's
on screen
those are Bernie and Warren and I'll
describe to you what's going on there
Bernie was immediately hurt when Joe
Biden entered the race and you see that
when Biden hit his high of around four
30 plus percent Bernie hit his low but
he since recovered and Bernie's now
pretty solidly in second place pulling
an average of just over 16 percent now
Elizabeth Warren on the other hand as I
told you a couple of weeks ago has been
slowly and steadily growing her support
and it's now at a campaign high she's
moved from being kind of in the five
percent area to 7 to 8 percent in most
polls she's now averaging right about 10
percent behind Bernie Sanders but not
drastically so so let's now look now
that we've seen who the three
frontrunners are let's look at who's
done and has no chance the frontrunners
clearly Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren behind them and then
there's the second sort of mini tier of
candidates which is Kamala Harris and
Pete Buddha judge Harris averaging about
7% Buddha judge averaging about 6% now
the people who have no chance and are
getting no traction and will likely
start dropping out soon after the
debates start are the folks who are
under 1% for sure and a lot of the
people under 2% as well okay so under 1%
and have no chance whatsoever Tulsi
Gabbard Bennett Bullock whom you may not
even have heard of Hickenlooper Seth
Moulton Bill DeBlasio john delaney
kirsten gillibrand marianne williamson
tim ryan they're all under 1% they just
have no chance ok I'm not telling them
to drop out I don't really care one way
or the other they're just non factors
they're done and I don't even know that
there's that much attention to be paid
to their prospects then you have the 1
to 2 percent range
oK you've got Andrew yang there you have
who Leon Castro you have Amy Klobuchar
who are between one and two percent
they're all so realistically done but if
you're at 2% you can sort of justify
staying in a little bit longer I know
that early I said I liked Andrew yang
and I still like Andrew yang I know that
three months ago he had like a
hypothetical path to the nomination if
he continued building support I'm not
calling him done now
I mean he's over 1% but if he doesn't
get to like 3 or 4% after
the first debate I don't know how he
justifies staying in and then caught in
this kind of no-man's land at more than
2% but less than anything significant
are cory booker at 2.2 and Beto or
Rourke at 3.8 I think they're also both
done but that's enough support to keep
raising money keep raising your public
profile by staying in so that's my
assessment right now if you disagree
with me on any of this let me know
politely ideally if there's someone in
the under 1% area that you think has a
shot tell me who and tell me why if
there's someone who's polling more than
three percent and you do think they
should get out right now tell me who and
tell me why and if you think that
there's someone who isn't doing well but
as soon as they get on the debate stage
they are going to be so impressive to
the voting public that they will rock it
up into at least the seven eight or nine
percent range tell me who and tell me
why people will be so impressed with
their debate skills we'll follow up
we'll do a poll on the YouTube community
tab about this and see where our
audience is on a lot of these candidates
and issues I'm back from my trip it's
really me I'm here and I'll talk about
my trip on the bonus show but sort of a
bummer to have to start my first show
back with something so disgusting and
despicable but this is the reality of
what's going on if you want to get a
sense really an actual real sense of
where the Trump administration is going
militarily you have only to look at Mike
Pence's speech over the weekend to West
Point graduates I'm going to show you a
clip today which cuts really to the
heart of neoconservative American
right-wing military aggression this is
the worst of the worst of the United
States this is a prime example of why so
many around the world are disgusted with
us listen closely to this one because
it's not getting the attention that it
deserves this is a from a speech that
Mike Pence gave over the weekend at West
Point which is a military academy it's
one of five US service
academies which are undergraduate
schools for commissioned officers in the
military in the case of West Point when
they graduate they have an eight year
commitment five years of active duty and
then three years in the reserves and
that's relevant for what we're about to
hear Mike Pence spoke to the graduating
class a few days ago and effectively let
slip that multiple wars are in play and
that graduates of West Point should
expect to be joining those wars
Paul Waldman caught this and wrote it up
in the Washington Post and I went back
and looked at the transcript and it's
sickening take a listen to what Mike
Pence said it's a virtual certainty that
you will fight on a battlefield for
America at some point your life you will
lead soldiers in combat it will happen
some of you will join the fight against
radical Islamic terrorists in
Afghanistan in Iraq some of you will
join the fight on the Korean Peninsula
and in the indo-pacific where North
Korea continues to threaten the peace
and an increasingly militarized China
challenges our presence in the region
some of you will join the fight in
Europe where an aggressive Russia seeks
to redraw international boundaries by
force and some of you may even be called
upon to serve in this hemisphere and
when that day comes I know you will move
to the sound of the guns do your duty
and you will fight it will happen
Afghanistan and Iraq I thought we were
out of Afghanistan and Iraq other than
exploring what our presence might be
nevermind combat the Korean Peninsula
against North Korea or against a
militarized China what we should be
expecting that we're going to fight in
Europe Mike Pence is talking about
fighting in Europe this hemisphere which
to me means Latin America my mind goes
in the immediate to Venezuela but there
are other possibilities and as Paul
Waldman points out in the Washington
Post peace
is saying not just that more Wars are
inevitable in some general sense he's
talking about their inevitability during
the time that these West Point graduates
are going to be either in active or
reserve duty now the defenders will say
I know what they're gonna come out and
say David Pence isn't being specific
fence isn't predicting he's simply
saying these are commissioned officers
who lead troops they are statistically
likely to see combat well that's not
true it has not been statistically
likely that West Point grads see combat
and Pence is not speaking in
generalities he's talking about combat
in Afghanistan and Iraq two places were
supposedly leaving into a degree have
left and the debate really has been
about shooters shouldn't the US have a
presence there and what should it look
like and for how long
Mike Pence is talking about combat
leading troops in Iraq and Afghanistan
this should be front page news Pence is
talking about the Korean Peninsula and
China
remember that Trump said we'll talk
about North Korea again today by the way
Trump said we won't need combat with
North Korea because Kim jong-un is such
a good guy and so trustworthy and a
sense of humor and his intelligence and
everything is just so lovely and Trump
trusts him despite the continued missile
launches which we will get to
and yet Pence is saying you should
expect that inevitably some of you are
going to end up in a combat zone in the
Korean Peninsula maybe involving an
increasingly militarized China and then
Europe I mean you're a which we could do
an entire show on pence talking about
that as well so eight years it's an
eight year commitment for these
graduates after they finish up their
four years at West Point five years of
active duty three years in the reserves
and Mike Pence is saying it's very
likely that in those eight years they
will see combat in some combination of
Iraq Afghanistan China North Korea
Europe and he says this hemisphere I'm
hearing Latin America I'm hearing
Venezuela maybe I guess we could take a
guess at where else we're thinking of
most q
could be a possibility I don't know
pence is referring to this as if it is a
foregone conclusion and a mere
inevitability it's a question of where
will each of you end up rather than if
and this is part of the totally toxic
and destructive that this is military
industrial excuse me military industrial
complex
this is neoconservative American foreign
policy at its worst it's all of these
things that depend on and assume and are
fueled by the tacit acceptance that it's
just a matter of figuring out which Wars
we're going to get involved in or start
rather than actually evaluating whether
we should be involved in these sorts of
conflicts or engagements at all
extremely disturbing almost beyond words
and not reported widely which is why I'm
leading the show with it today there is
a completely mind-blowing new claim in a
book which says that Robert Muller felt
so strongly that Donald Trump had
actually committed criminal obstruction
that Moeller drafted indictment
documents against Donald Trump now
eventually as we know Muller punted on
the issue of obstruction and Donald
Trump he said in his report that
although there was quote substantial
evidence of Donald Trump's obstruction
and I believe it was eight of the
possible 14 instances of obstruction for
political reasons Robert Muller decided
not to decide about indictment on
obstruction and sort of punted to Donald
Trump's hand-picked Attorney General
William bar who obviously no surprise
said yeah we're not going to indict
Donald Trump but is the claim made in
the book true
I don't know I'm gonna lay it all out
for you and maybe we can figure it out
this is from Michael Wolf's latest book
now you might remember Michael Wolfe
wrote his previous book fire and fury
which had all sorts of explosive claims
about Donald Trump and his
administration and the people around him
some of which have not been proven to be
true or at least have not been
independently corroborated outside of
the book itself so we now get to Michael
new book which is called siege Trump
under fire and what wolf says is that
Robert Muller had actually drawn up a
three count obstruction of justice
indictment against President Donald
Trump but that eventually he didn't file
it and the Guardian asked a spokesman
for robert muller about this and mullux
miller spokesman is flat-out just saying
didn't happen and is quoted as saying
the documents that you've described do
not exist now that language is relevant
at least possibly and I'll get back to
that in a second let's talk about wolf
sources wolf sites internal documents
given to him by sources close to the
office of the Special Counsel okay now
what makes this claim not like other
random or particularly salacious claims
that have been made is that the
documents exist the Guardian has looked
at the documents that Michael wolf has
there is a document which Michael wolf
gave to the Guardian which says under
Title 18 US Code subsection 1505 that
the president this is a draft indictment
the president is charged with corruptly
or by threats of force or threatening
communication influencing obstructing or
impeding a pending proceeding before a
department or agency of the United
States the second count in this draft
indictment that Michael wolf looked at
and showed to the Guardian is a count
under Section 1512 charging the
president with tampering with a witness
victim or informant the third count in
this document that the Guardian has
looked at is under section 1513 charging
Donald Trump with retaliating against
the witness victim or informant wolf
says that the documents claim that
Trump's obstruction started on day seven
of his administration and wolf has
endless additional documents including a
bunch of internal memos about whether or
not the president can be indicted in the
consensus of those documents as that the
answer is yes so the question is are the
documents real is Muller's spokesperson
lying when he denies the existence of
the documents are the documents fake
if they're fake who fake them is it wolf
is it whoever gave them to wolf is it
somebody else there has to be some
objective truth here either this is real
or it is not and it appears to be binary
except there is a sort of vocabulary
semantics possibility here if you look
again at the statement from Robert
Muller spokesperson he said quote the
documents described do not exist these
are lawyers okay
documents described do not exist that is
the present tense that is very different
than saying the documents never existed
the claim from Michael wolf is that the
documents existed they were drafted and
that they were scrapped that is one
possibility as to how everybody is
telling the truth there well could have
been a draft indictment against Donald
Trump it could have been scrapped and
therefore in a technical sense
Moeller spokesperson is right the
documents do not exist today May 29 29
teen there's another possibility that
the documents contained four counts
against Donald Trump and not three
technically that means that a document
containing three counts against Trump
doesn't exist but one containing four or
maybe two counts could exist
The Guardian looked at the documents and
they certainly aren't saying that the
documents are bogus and we have the
denial from Moeller spokesperson which
could potentially be a very carefully
crafted non denial I don't know
hopefully we'll know the truth about
these documents sometime soon but the
end result of all of this is molars got
to testify right molars silence is a
growing problem it seems he may be sort
of willing to testify before the House
Judiciary Committee if it's behind
closed doors but will he won't he I
don't know the growing questions around
this really make it necessary for him to
sit down and most importantly remember
what portion of the country has read the
Moller report is it 1% is it 2% maybe 5%
whatever that number is it's way too low
and Robert Muller testifying
ideally publicly would actually serve
the purpose of informing people about
what
in the report most of which remains
unknown to the majority of them American
population and that's why it's so
important that Muller testify that's why
it's so important that the house
formally start a debate about
impeachment to get the content of the
report out to more than just the I don't
know one two or five percent of the
American public that has read it let me
know what you think about these claims
by Michael Wolfe the documents the
Guardians review of the documents I
don't know what to think but I do think
it's possible that the documents are
real and that the denial from Moeller
spokesperson has a very narrow meaning
that we should be interpreting I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I do want
to hear from you